voilà
léonard je ne suis pas mécontent de moi
le dîner que j'ai offert hier soir à
tous mes amis étaient formidables et
puis alors que l'ambiance est oui
c'était pas triste en effet je me suis
amusé comme un petit fou comme 1 petit
four 1 1 n'ont enfin je veux dire que je
me suis amusé comme un petit fou et que
j'ai mangé tous les petits fours quoi
c'était toi abattu ne manque pas
d'audace
il était là pour être mangés
oui oui
évidemment
c'est ce que j'ai fait
je te pardonne mais je suis trop bon
c'est agréable de recevoir ses amis et
le lendemain quand il faut tout ranger
et bien c'est beaucoup moins drôle
[Musique]
trouve ça très rigolo moi de te regarder
faire le ménage et la vaisselle
comment peux-tu avoir le courage de me
regarder travailler sans m'aider
mais je ne sais pas mais j'arrive très
bien tu sais rien lequel de nous deux a
reçu ses amis hier soir c'est moi
évidemment et on ne fait pas travailler
les invités rien ce soir c'est moi qui
reçoit et demain c'est moi qui
arrangerait tout voilà à un bon et où
s'il te plait ou
b dans cette maison évidemment je vais
faire les choses en grand voyons
je mettrai la table là derrière l'arbre
vas-y fais-le
écoutant imaginons la soul man ray ban
très bien ensuite atteint je mettrai des
guirlandes à des guirlandes un peu
partout chat
aller voilà
comme ça ça va au
sera éblouissant
est-ce que tu t'en moques de moi espèces
d'un renard stupide un oui mais ça ne
ment pas mon pauvre quoi eh bien tu vas
le savoir étant donné que tu refuses de
média arrangées il n'est pas question
que tu reçoives tes amis chez moi dans
mes meubles et donc ma salle à manger
non mauvais caractère et bien trompé
je sais pas comment ni où je donnerai ma
réception mais je la donnerai et comme
je ne suis pas rancunier moi je t'invite
derrière jeu recevra un carton par la
poste
ça alors les enfants écoutent et la
curieuse invitation que j'aime recevoir
françois tu me ferait un très grand
plaisir en acceptant de bien vouloir
dîner ce soir dans à mal tenue de soirée
exigée et c'est signé léonard
vous rendez compte dans sa malle
mais oui bon évidemment je suis pas très
gros ça va léonard lui est tout petit
mais quand même
juste moi je cherchais j'ai un conseil à
vous demander en mariage libre frappé à
la bonne porte vous savez que j'adore
donner des conseils et de plus goûteux
réf et bien voilà je suis invité ce soir
à dîner et j'aimerais que vous
choisissiez avec moi l'art en gros mais
avaient plaisir julie alors celle-ci
avait fait le choix est complexe à suhr
rapide
elles sont tellement sentiments celle ci
est celle ci
une idée
ce sera toi que julie portera sa
soirée
j'espère qu'elle va plaire à léonard
vous avez bien dit leonard wiki direz
vous que je suis invité ce soir dans ses
annales
cessera charmant nous alors oui en effet
ça aurait pu l'être si je n'étais pas
également invités
en effet trois dans sa malle ça va être
un peu étrange pour enfin tant pis je ne
mettrai pas ma superbe europe de mousse
les noms cela gagnera un peu de place
pour et bien moi je vais choisir une
autre europe celle là est trop large
tenue celle ci est très étroit je pense
que ça ira en trajet
il est complètement ma boule sera en
arme et il a dû tomber sur le crâne
quelle plaisanterie
tout seul nous en avons organisé pour
moi hardin et donc sa
maladie je sais mais aussi le méritait
françois et moi aussi je suis de la
petite faith et moi aussi heureusement
il ne m'a pas oublié mais quelle
prétention vouloir nous faire tenir tout
cela va mal enfin allons-y quand même
il va y avoir du sport
quand les enfants entraient en trait
c'est gentil d'avoir répondu à mon appel
j'ai besoin de votre aide puis je
comptais sur vous oui très bien je suis
tombé vous savez peut-être que j'ai
invité juil françois mademoiselle futé
et et casimir à venir dîner dans ma il
est évident que c'est impossible qu'ils
entrent tous dans ma malle elle est
beaucoup trop petit alors j'ai shi et
j'ai trouvé là sur les gens regardent
voile voici un plan jamais
je les dessine et vous le voyez
vous avez bien compris mon plan
alors allez au travail vous allez à
l'est d'oran chercher les planches qui
sont à l'extérieur voilà devant la
maison très bien
quand je pense qu'en ce moment même au
jardin il doit me prendre pour un fou
ils vont tous être plutôt surpris
heureusement que vous êtes là les
enfants pour faire le travail pas parce
que moi il faut que je cuisine et puis
en plus je n'ai jamais pu planter un
clou sont tapés sur le doigt alors
allez-y très bien
parfait aux bravo il est super bien les
instructions 1
en
fait
les invités
dont la table est mise pour
être surpris ça ils vont addition
c'est nous les junies gels et françois
rey mais bien sûr non seulement vous le
pouvez mais vous le devez
donc saisi news monsieur nous nous
sommes trompés de maison et que c est
nous mais la maison de casimir tu reçois
je t'assure tu as raison c'est bien les
honore
merad mais que s'est il est comme ça
qu'est ce que c'est que ça la malle
mais elle était normal y'a pas d'autres
nous mettait enfin voyons rentrée ne
restez pas chez casimir fait plaisir
c'est très très très fins et c'est très
bien meublé c'était très bon à l'aller
en attendant vous prendrez bien un peu
de jus de carotte ou domicile tenait
cela avec
merci
mais ça a dit qu là je vais
l'écrabouiller des cochons mettrait le
pied dessus ça petitement alors bonjour
mais ne t'énerve pas
magnani me va pas mais je ne peux pas il
m'a invité et puis j'ai faim moi non je
vais y aller mais j'en resterais à
l'extérieur de la malle aux
avocats
[Musique]
merci mademoiselle fuite et puis
d'ailleurs je trouve que nous devrions
tous restés à l'extérieur car à part
julie qui a une taille de guêpe je ne
vois pas qui pourrait rentrer enfin
je vous attends avec impatience
après vous connaissez tous le monde je
mets
tu t'es déjà là je lis tu as vraiment
une très jolie robe à merci casino toi
aussi tu es très élégant
j'ai
trouvé dans la mort dans
la malle mais quasi 10 h au motel nous
sommes effectivement dans la main
alors je n'avais même pas rendu compte
ayant l'air de re de rien pour ne pas
avoir l'air idiot non allez allez
prenez beaucoup hein c'est une
spécialité de mon pays voilà bien
volontiers
le bravo bravo les honneurs c'est c'est
délicieux
j'en avais pas d'appétit oui moi aussi
si je peux en avoir encore un petit peu
les honneurs s'il te plaît mais avec
léonard soyons honnêtes à prédire il ya
quelque chose qui le gêne
comment se fait-il que tu as mal soit
devenue énorme tout d'un coup
mais c'est parce que depuis quelques
temps et mangent beaucoup trop alors
bien sûr elle grossit grossit un gros c
mais cette fois ça mais mais elle tient
presque toute la place dans la maison où
gouv fr ou veste noire mauroy en casimir
ne t'inquiète pas dès demain elle se met
au régime amaigrissant dans huit jours 1
sera redevenu comme avant vraiment
tu m'as fait peur
la soirée
[Musique]